Jim Carrey's girlfriend Katriona White's
death officially ruled a suicide the 30
year old was found dead inside her home
on September 28th on Tuesday an autopsy
report from the Los Angeles County
coroner's office confirmed her death was
caused by quote multiple drugs effect
the report listed for prescription drugs
that were present in her system
including painkillers beta blockers and
a sleep aid the docs indicate three of
the prescriptions were under the name
Arthur King the coroner also reported
finding a text message from Carrie on
white cell phone asking if she knew
where painkillers prescribed to him went
the coroner concluded quote given this
it appears likely that the bottles for
Arthur King found on White's bedside
table were the prescriptions he was
referring to the coroner gave details
about the letter and note addressed to
Carrie found at White's home the letter
requested her belongings be sold money
be given to family and deferred
instructions for her burial service to
carry another sealed note was more
personal in addressed her breakup with
the actor